zwei eurofighter der deutschen
bundeswehr haben ein russisches
aufklärungsflugzeug vor der insel rügen
abgedrängt die maschine war unerlaubt in
den deutschen luftraum eingedrungen
zuletzt gab es ähnliche vorfälle auch
schon in dänemark und in schweden die
alarmrotte aus den zwei deutschen
maschinen begleitete das russische
flugzeug dann im internationalen
luftraum weg von deutschland
und darüber wollen wir sprechen mit dem
ehemaligen deutschen nato general hans
lothar domröse schon guten tag herr
domröse
schwimmen können sie uns mal sagen was
dieses russische sogenannte
aufklärungsflugzeug im deutschen
luftraum gesucht haben könnte
das weiß ich nicht aber vielleicht
sollten die russen ja mal testen ob wir
wach sind das könnte die gute nachricht
ist wir haben 365 tage 24 stunden am tag
in bereitschaft der inspekteur der
luftwaffe hat einen alarm zentrum das
nicht in kalkar wie alle wissen
dass rund um die uhr unsere
haben sind nach 15 minuten in der luft
das ist was so ist dass ich auch in lage
gewesen dass unbekannte flugzeug ist
zunächst erkannt worden dann steigen die
auf und durch anzeigen wenn sie nur funk
reagieren sollte man an dass er folgen
soll oder ausreichen sondern das ist ja
offensichtlich geschehen
was passiert wenn das nicht passiert
also wenn die russischen maschinen jetzt
nicht auf diese kommandos von den
deutschen alarmrotte gehört hätten
ja ich hätte mich gerne zurück an dr
peter schroth haben als unser
verteidigungsminister als das eingeführt
wurde luftraum sicherheitsgesetz den
schlimmsten fall wird es zum abschluss
kommen wenn man gefahr nicht deuten kann
also da könnte irgendein wir können das
flugzeuge richtung atomkraftwerk fliegen
um es zu sprechen auf dem marktplatz
fliegen man hier kann das ja in etwa
berechnen also man wird dran bleiben man
wird warnschüsse abgeben in die luft so
dass er das sieht spur und dann im
zweifelsfall die freigabe holen ist eine
höhere verantwortung
den speckgürtel familie trägt um
deutschland zu sichern nun kommt so was
ja durchaus häufiger mal vor dass
flugzeuge in ausländische lufträume
eindringen aber nun gerade jetzt vor dem
hintergrund des russischen
angriffskrieges ist das schon eine
provokation von russland oder nicht oder
kann man das nicht so verstehen
na ja ich versuche letzte gelassen zu
sein aber es ist schon eine mittlere
frechheit denn es ist ja nicht nur
deutschland gewesen hierbei rügen oder
diese natürliche leute aus lage die
alarm mäßig gestartet sind es war ja
schweden dänemark und wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe aus der presse
hat der die schwedische regierung den
botschafter einbestellt um das
missfallen auszudrücken also die
häufigkeit dieser aktionen könnte man
als test der nato verstehen aber die
antwort ist da an die nato staaten
dänemark schweden noch eu bald nato
haben reagiert und das ist die gute
nachricht wir sind geschützt durch
unsere systeme erklären sie uns noch mal
ganz genau wie läuft es so ein abdrängen
so ein verfahren ab wie ist da die
alarmkette
naja zunächst nimmt man etwas war auf
dem radarschirm in den in den zentren
und verteilungszentren das ist selbst
teil kann man sieht irgend ein
unbekanntes flugobjekt manchmal so
unterschiedlichen definieren danach wenn
das nicht gelingt und kontakt
aufzunehmen alarm und sie sehen ja die
bilder die sich gerade im hintergrund
zeigen innerhalb von 15 minuten sind
diese den jungs und mädchen in der luft
und nähert sich dem flugzeug an und man
weiß ja wo es und man gibt zeichen im
zweifelsfall um ab zu deuten im
schlimmsten fall wenn keine reaktion ist
mit warnschüssen glauben sie es braucht
jetzt eine gegenreaktion oder sollte man
das tunlichst unterlassen
die reaktion nein wir würden ja nicht
nach russland fliegen zuerst noch deren
systeme funktionieren da gibt es keine
gegenreaktion wir können uns wirklich
stolz sein dass hier was klappt sehr gut
glaubt in der vorgeschriebenen zeit und
wachsamkeit ist der preis der freiheit
dies wird die lupe weitermachen und die
alliierten streitkräfte
wir haben ja über 200 flugzeuge in einer
art zur verfügung also da muss man auch
das vertrauen
dass alles gut gegangen es ist trotzdem
die provokation da haben sie recht
vielen dank an den ehemaligen deutsche
nato-general für diese einschätzung hans
lothar domröse
vielen dank